it was a wonderful man and he was my
professor at Columbia I read his book
when I was 19 at the University of
Nebraska and I'd started investing when
I was 11 I started reading about it when
I was like seven
so I'd gone through all I've read every
book in the Omaha Public Library that
was on by the time I was twelve on
investing in stock market and I had a
lot of fun but I never really found out
I never got grounded to anything and it
was it was entertaining but it wasn't
gonna be profitable and then I read
Graham's book the Intelligent Investor
when I was at the University of Nebraska
and pulled open the whole thing up to me
and then Graham and his low-teens
looked around and he looked at the
people he admired and he said I want to
be admire so why don't I just behave
like them and they found there was
nothing impossible about behaving like
them well the biggest lesson in a sense
I got is the power of unconditional love
I think there is no power on earth like
unconditional love I think that if you
offer that to your child
I mean you 90 percent of the way home to
know you always can come back that is
huge in life that takes you a long long
way and I would say that every parent
out there that can extend that to their
child at a very young age it's gonna
make for a better human day you just
watched two amazing clips and Warren
Buffett take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]